It is my pleasure to
introduce Martha Pollack.
Dr. Pollack is the 14th
president of Cornell University.
As faculty at the University of Michigan,
Dr. Pollack and Dr.
Jahanian forged a strong friendship.
I'm pretty sure that neither of them
imagined that they'd be here today as
president of two of the best
universities in the United States.
Their presidency's come at an important
time in history, when we're presented
with new opportunities and
challenges on a daily basis.
Technology is moving
forward at an amazing pace.
It's impacting all areas of research,
transforming how we teach and
blending the lines between disciplines.
Doctors Jahanian and Pollack are the right
time of leader at the right time -
bold, innovative, forward thinking.
We need to make our institutions
a transformational part of this time.
Since becoming the president of
Cornell University about a year and
a half ago, Dr. Pollack has demonstrated
a strong commitment to sustaining and
enhancing Cornell's academic
distinction while enhancing equality,
diversity and inclusivity.
She is supporting the university's
expansion into New York City,
where it has programs that range from
architecture to technology to medicine.
Dr. Pollack came to Cornell University
from the University of Michigan,
where she was provost and executive
vice president for academic affairs.
Before her tenure at Michigan,
she actually served on the University of
Pittsburgh's faculty, so
welcome back to Pittsburgh.
[LAUGH]
Dr. Pollack is renowned for
her contributions in computer science and
artificial intelligence.
Her research focuses on automated
planning, temporal reasoning and
constraint satisfaction.
She has designed intelligent technology to
assist people with cognitive impairments
and their caregivers.
Dr. Pollack has also served as
president of the Association for
the Advancement of
Artificial Intelligence
and was a member of
the advisory committee for
the National Science
Foundation's Computers and
Information Science Engineering Division
and a member of the Board of the Directors
of the Computing Research Association.
Please join me in welcoming Dr.
Martha Pollack.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you, Rebecca,
good morning to all of you.
I'm truly honored to be here today for the
inauguration of my colleague and friend,
Farnam Jahanian as the tenth president
of Carnegie Mellon University.
Most of you probably don't know this,
but there is an historical connection
between Carnegie Mellon and
my own university, Cornell.
Andrew Carnegie was one of Cornell's first
trustees, elected to that role in 1890.
Later, honoring his passion for music,
Carnegie donated to Cornell a magnificent
organ to celebrate the 80th birthday of
our first president, Andrew Dickson White.
Alas, the organ suffered an ignoble fate.
Its air intake, for some inexplicable
reason, was located in the men's bathroom.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] And in 1935,
there was a plumbing failure that
fill that room with water.
Unaware of this, the university organist
sat down at the instrument, and
according to the historical account,
blew a mighty crescendo,
which filled the leather organ
pouches with water, ruining them.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Perhaps we'd have been even better off
with a gift of bagpipes.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now,
there is also a long time
connection between Farnam and me,
although of course not as long
as between our universities.
As Rebecca said, Farnam and I met about
20 years ago when we were both faculty
members in Computer Science and
Engineering at the University of Michigan.
I later became chair of CSE, and
Farnam succeeded me in that role.
Later, he became provost
here at Carnegie Mellon
a few years after I had
become provost at Michigan
and he started as interim president
here just a couple of months after I
became Cornell's president.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> But
I'm gonna take that couple of
months head start seriously and
imagine that it gives me the right to
offer him some advice on leadership.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Specifically, I'd like to quote Hopper,
the grasshopper in the animated
movie "A Bug's Life" who said this,
[I] quote, "first rule of leadership,
everything is your fault."
>> [LAUGH]
>> I hate to tell you this Farnam, but
Hopper's right, especially when
you're the president of a university.
But really, having everything be
your fault is a fair trade-off for
all that is wonderful about
being a university president.
It is, as I know Farnam appreciates,
a huge privilege to lead a university,
especially a great one
like Carnegie Mellon.
Universities are institutions that
are second-to-none in changing lives.
We change the lives of our students.
We change the lives of the communities
into which our students graduate
and we change the lives of all those
who are touched by the research and
the scholarship of our faculty.
Farnam, I can assure you, is the perfect
choice to lead Carnegie Mellon and
to ensure that it continues its proud
tradition of changing lives for
the better.
He has a range of experience that's
an extraordinary fit for this university.
Experience in academia, where he's
been a talented and dedicated teacher,
as well as a renowned researcher whose
discoveries have had broad impact.
Experience in industry,
where he founded a very successful
network security startup company.
And experience in government,
where he served in major roles at
the National Science Foundation,
the National Research
Council's Computer Science and
Telecommunications board, and more.
But beyond all that,
what I want you to know is that Farnam
also has a set of personal characteristics
that are in complete alignment
with Carnegie Mellon's culture.
He is a person of high
integrity who values and
exhibits creativity,
innovation and entrepreneurship.
He values and promotes mentorship and
the development of
leadership skills as essential to
preparing students for today's world.
He appreciates the importance of
a university supporting a breadth of
intellectual inquiry.
But he also has a particular passion for
translational research that produces
results that directly benefit society.
He's focused on the ways in
which technology can enhance
all aspects of the university,
from teaching to research, to operations.
A few years ago,
when Alan G. Merten retired from
the presidency of George Mason University,
he said this, [I] quote,
"Do I like being a university president?
I don't know, but
I do know that I have loved being
George Mason University's president.
Some of my friends
are university presidents.
I wouldn't wanna be where they are and
they probably wouldn't wanna be here.
These jobs could look a lot a like,
but they are not."
End quote.
Search committees look for university
presidents who fit their university, and
I can't imagine Carnegie Mellon finding
someone who fits better than Farnam.
He will be a brilliant and inspired
leader for this wonderful university.
And who knows?
He may even learn to play the bag pipes.
>> [APPLAUSE]